[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
and there's a perfect fit Dear John and
Hank it's a County podcast about death
where two brothers we will answer your
questions two viewed abuse advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John my
brother how are you doing Hank I'm doing
great it's a beautiful day here in
Indianapolis spring has sprung what are
the e coming say spring is like a
perhaps hand it those buds on the trees
the hope newness I am a little stressed
out to be completely honest with you but
there's no use in talking about that the
only thing that we should talk about is
is spring and how there are flowers and
hoga yeah we're gonna look at the the
parts of the plants that are new and not
gray and they're coming out and not
think about all the trouble troubles of
the world there are so many troubles of
the world John I'm not even sure what
I'm gonna make my video about this week
because I feel overwhelmed by the
troubles of the world but maybe I should
just make my video about spring and
about little pieces of plants that are
not the color of death I do want to say
like so so I'm going to Amsterdam for
VidCon great sit and I've never been to
Amsterdam and I know that you've spent a
lot of time in Amsterdam and that you
like it a lot did you know that in April
the entire city of Amsterdam becomes
entirely booked and that you should
probably probably I don't know life pro
tip for from an adult to other adults I
don't know book your hotel more than two
weeks in advance because last night I
was sitting in a panic as I realized
that that literally it says on Expedia
it's like 98 percent of hotel rooms in
Amsterdam are booked and I was like
that's not real right and then one after
the other after the other these hotels
literally have no rooms so I got a hotel
room in Amsterdam John it might not be
the best one but it was certainly
expensive ya know it is kind of the time
of year to go to Amsterdam there's the
the spring snow as they call it the
falling out of the trees the even
beautiful like flowers basically coating
the city hmm and also the weather is
nice it's just lovely and we should
say that there will be tickets available
to vidcon amsterdam at the door if
you're in amsterdam or there abouts and
want to come to vidcon europe please do
and other than that Hank the only other
thing I wanted to say on that topic was
that since you have never been to
Amsterdam before I really hope you go
back and listen to the episode of the
podcast where I gave advice to that
tourist who was going to Amsterdam about
what they should see because there's no
way I'm going through it with you again
just because you're my brother I
appreciate that I've gotten a fair good
a good amount of advice I think but
there's certainly a lot to see when I go
to visit a new city I almost always like
the thing that I want to do is just walk
around and I know it's a great city for
walking yeah I almost enjoy that more
than like going to you know the gardens
or the museums I just like to see people
living the lives and in their in the way
that is you know maybe like familiar but
different than the way that I I live my
life in my town and the things that are
familiar and the things that are
different allowing me to sort of see
humanity more so to make just it's not
like I see a new humanity differently
it's just like it becomes more clear
that that we are us and and I get to
watch it happen do you have a short poem
for us today John I think what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna read you half of a poem
about spring by EE Cummings that's gonna
make it short I'm just gonna read the
second half plan that's my strategy I'm
sure that he won't mind well he won't
mind because he died in 1962 spring is
like a perhaps hand in a window
carefully to and fro moving new and old
things while people stare carefully
moving a perhaps fraction of flower here
placing an inch of air there and without
breaking anything hmm I like it nice
little E Cummings stanza about a stanza
oh I'm so excited for spring Hank let's
answer some questions from our beloved
listeners can I start oh sure
all right this question comes from
Cormac who asks Dear John and Hank I've
long been unhappy with my signature with
it just being my name clumsily
inconsistently written in the cursive
writing I stopped using at the age of 12
adults seemed to have lovely consistent
yet illegible sick
I've now become paranoid as I approach
adulthood that I've missed some
important event whereupon I was supposed
to gain a lovely signature of my own I
figured you two have had your fair share
of signatures and have lovely flowing
ones I feel like Hank Azaria flowing one
I'm not sure that I have a lovely
flowing one as such anyway so I'm
seeking urgent help for my growing
mini-crisis memento vobis acid err a
Cormac possibly Cormac John have you
ever in your life consciously changed to
your signature like did you have that
that oh yes okay like you thought about
and you're like I'm gonna have so I had
this signature I was I did develop a
signature when I was in high school and
the idea was the signature would be all
acute angles no curves just very acute
angles and I drew the Oh as a kind of a
diamond and everything was extremely
acute in its angling and that was my
signature
even after Looking for Alaska was
published if you find the first like few
hundred books I signed it looks like
that it's a very small real very legible
weirdly acute angled series of letters
and then slowly over time I developed a
new signature called the J scribble that
it's just a J followed by a scribble I
want to see this old signature oh man
it's yeah I don't know maybe I'll try to
I'll try to dig one up for you
I know Eileen Cooper has won my mentor
cuz that she has the first book I ever
signed but I don't know I don't know how
you would find them exactly I I did just
find an amazing picture of someone who
took your signature and drew and this
has happened a number of times where
people will take your the signature that
you signed in a book and then turn it
into something and this person has
turned it into some kind of water bird
which is lovely yep but yes John you do
have you do have the J scribble and and
it's a it's almost it's almost more
famous than you are at this point but I
what I what I what I want to say to DES
Carmack is
what this this tends to be something
that happens accidentally unless you're
really sort of obsessed with yourself
which is what happened to me and I like
sat there at my job where I was I worked
in a laboratory after college and I
hated my signature because it was small
and it was as you say it was basically
how I wrote in cursive when I turned 12
and that was as far as I knew about
cursive and this is a this is a like I
think this is a problem for a lot of
people right now because we don't write
in cursive anymore because we don't have
to because cursive speeds up writing but
not nearly as much as typing so we don't
really know how to write in cursive and
so we don't really adapt our cursive
handwriting is beyond like what we're
taught in elementary school even if
that's taught at all anymore which I
don't know so you have to do you kind of
have to develop a signature now you have
to do it on your own you have to have an
idea and be like I'm gonna do this thing
now you also have to go to the bank and
like resubmit a signature card and be
like I have a new signature now which is
weird if you have if you like use checks
and stuff and have to have your checks
work because I did do this and they were
like that's not your signature and I was
like it is now anyway oh my god this is
this is an extremely embarrassing story
Hank this is way more embarrassing than
my acute angle signature no I completely
agree
I completely agree that it's
embarrassing but I did develop a new
signature and I did it just like one
letter at a time and like I did a bunch
of different ones and then I did it a
bunch of times and I changed my
signature and I am glad I did it but I
am embarrassed that I did it oh yeah no
I am extremely embarrassed on your
behalf both of those things can be true
though right yeah I mean uh here's the
thing Cormack it doesn't really matter
that much I don't think you should be
too hard on yourself because in the end
if your signature is legible I actually
think that's cooler than if your
signature is illegible so I would stick
with your current legible signature and
just kind of own it mm-hmm
own that 12 year old cursive as yours
and you'll find that it
comes yours my my signature has gone
through one other layer of
simplification Hank now that I'm
actually googling it and looking at old
signatures which is that I used to have
a very distinctive H I used to have
essentially a J know Oh a distinctive H
and then a scribble and I have
eliminated that H because it was it was
a wasted it was a wasted keystroke you
design a lot of books yeah
well and that's the other thing that I
will say about signature is is that
these like you don't end up with a
signature because you came up with it
one day usually and like I my signature
has certainly changed since I
quote-unquote developed it while I was
skeeving off from work that like you
just if you do it a bunch of times it
starts to take on a different shape and
it starts to look a little more flowy
and your hand decides what to do and
yeah so just sit there with a piece of
paper do it a bunch of times and maybe
move your hand a little bit more than
you normally would and eventually you'll
be like that looks like a signature okay
I think I think we've probably plumbed
the depths I think it's a legitimate
problem that we needed to address and
I'm glad that we did this question is
from Caleb and I've been wanting to hit
this one because we've gotten this
question in multiple different forums
over the years and I'm glad over the
years oh the years of us doing this
podcast
Caleb asks dear Hank and John on our
recent episode of the pod you mentioned
how we Americans waste a tremendous
amount of water flushing toilets
unnecessarily I mean that's not the
biggest way that we waste water to be
clear the biggest way that we waste
water is lawns why is that bad I always
hear that conserving water is good for
the environment but isn't all that water
just going down the drain useful or not
being reintroduced to the environment
eventually and resuming its course in
the hydrological cycle is the energy it
required slash carbon footprint of
moving the water into the house is that
what's the problem would peeing in the
trees behind my house be a better
alternative to flushing every time I use
the toilet narwhals and spatulas Caleb
oh gosh yes well let me just start
because this is Hanks area of expertise
not mine but let me just start with your
last question first which is that yes
you should always
in the trees behind your house rather
than being in a toilet uh well you know
it's settled then okay Caleb John has
your answer for you get out get out in
your backyard don't mind the neighbors
and water some trees nope but Caleb just
so you understand like I didn't
understand this until I was like 33
years old and Hank explained it to me
the water in the toilet is the same as
the water that you drink like it it has
been treated in the exact same process I
did not know that Hank I thought that
like there were two kinds of water I had
no idea that the water that we put on
our lawns to water our lawns is like the
exact same as the water that comes out
of my tap because that seems ludicrously
inefficient yeah well it turns out that
it's actually efficient because running
two sets of pipes to a house would be
much would be twice as hard as running
one set of pipes to a house so that's
the in the vast majority of places
that's the way that it gets done there
are some places that use these different
water for watering but usually those are
like large consumers like college
campuses or something like that
so the yeah the sitch is that one that
there are two really good reasons to
conserve water
one is that it's not infinite and that
we use more water than is in a lot of
places we use more water than is
currently being resupplied to the area
and we do that by bringing water out of
underground lakes called aquifers and
those aquifers run out of water
eventually like they are not like they
are not reach refilling as fast as we
are direct pumping water out of them so
that's a scary thing
the vast majority the reason why is not
residential consumption though it that
is a piece of the pie the big consumer
is agriculture for the most part so make
it make them food for us to eat but but
could but residential consumption
especially in city areas is a really big
part of aquifer depletion the other
thing is that yes it is it is energy it
is fossil fuels that are used to pump
water around the world they have to get
it
so that it comes out of here out of your
tap and that's usually done by pumping
water up into something that has some
elevation and then letting gravity do
that work that's what water towers are
so you have to pump the water up into
the water tower and then it falls out of
the water tower and that pressure is
what pushes is out of your tap and then
once it goes out of your tap and it gets
flushed down into the pipes you have to
pump it back up so that it can then flow
down to the sewage treatment plant
unless you have a septic system so
there's a huge amount of water that goes
or a huge amount of energy that goes
into moving water around treating that
water so that it is potable and then
treating it once that it is once it's
dirty again so that you can be put into
the rivers without it being too too
dirty to go into the into back into the
water supply
so lots lots of energy goes into that
process and in fact in a recent vlog for
this video you'll see a coal-fired power
plant that just in sort of the
background when I was talking about Glen
Canyon and that coal-fired power plant
was built almost entirely to pump water
to from you know from sort of Glen
Canyon area to places where that that
water needs to be as part of the central
Arizona Project and and a lot of places
in California the water has to get
pumped over mountains to it you know for
what Los Angeles to have enough water
for its residence and that is very a
hugely energy intensive process because
if you ever lifted a five-gallon bucket
of water you know how much it weighs and
that is what has to get happened with
every five gallons of water that gets
consumed in California so that's the
situation and yes you should be careful
about how much water you consume
specifically you should pee in the woods
or just but you know it doesn't be in
the woods just wherever or alternately
just hold it I don't know if there's any
sign buying the tank but I find
sometimes that if I hold it for long
enough I stop having to go Wow
that definitely works with poo has never
worked for me with pee alright well I'm
just telling you I think that there's
something there this next question comes
from Devon Hank who writes dear john and
hank i love my solution to the water
crisis has just hold it anyway
Dear John and Hank I have a pet snake
I've had him for about six months now
and everything's going fine however my
dad does not know that I have a pet
snake
at home right now until I go to college
this fall but I'm not sure how my dad
will react to the snake I'm 18 but he
did tell me not to get a pet snake while
I was still in the house
he'll probably learn about the secret
snake when I'm packing up to go to
college if not sooner my question is how
would you react if your child got a pet
you told them not to get and then hid it
from you for several months dftba
Devin Devin how big is your house that
you're able to have a secret snake oh
man
okay also also why are you gotta tell
your dad about the snake yeah like
you've lied for so long just keep lying
you know this question reminded me of
Hank when I was in high school I had a
friend who shall remain nameless who
grew pot in his bathroom like he had
grow lights and in the bathtub in his
bathroom and and it worked for like
seven months and then eventually like
one day his father was like I need to go
to the bathroom and was like why is it
so bright in here and he pulled back the
shower curtain and like there was like
you know medium sized I want a growing
operation I actually disagree with you
Hank I think that Devin needs to tell
his father about the snake posthaste
no no Devin needed to tell his father
about the snake before he got the snake
but there is an end in sight and all
like all you have to do is make it to
the end and then you will not have had
to have lied it will just it will be oh
if you can make it to college with the
snake then you basically it's basically
like you never did it right no but I
think the issue is that like when
they're packing up to go to college it's
gonna be like Devin and dad packing the
car and then it
very end Devon's gonna be like well dad
I hmm
well can you just it's good to see you
can you go out for about an hour and
then I'll leave for college yes no look
this is a perfect opportunity for Devon
who is a person who is coming into their
own as a and like learning how to
problem-solve in big in difficult ways
to problem-solve in a big and difficult
way what are the potential ways to get
that snake to school without dad seeing
it can you like wrap it up at a carpet
can you ship it ahead can you get a
second cut can you like have a friend
with an illicit car how far is college
can you just set like can you just like
wrap the snake around your belly with
like an ace bandage can just make it
into aquarium once you get there yeah
just yeah what is like you had there has
to be a solution and then no you know
dad finds if dad finds out about it then
it dad is at least like well I see that
you have gone through lengths to and I
am impressed by your ability to try and
keep this a secret from me good job with
the lies son no no no you're approaching
this in completely the wrong way Hank
the right thing to do in this situation
all right stick with me for a second
here you let the snake out in the house
okay you let the snake out in the house
at a time when you know your father is
going to be around like let's say you
let it out in the kitchen and and then
like maybe fifteen thirty minutes later
you hear a scream and it's your dad and
you come in to the kitchen and you're
like what's up dad and he's like there
is a snake in the house and you're like
oh no that's terrible
I'll catch it I'll get it and then you
catch the snake and then you say you
know what dad what if I just kept the
snake this seems like a dangerous
prospect for the snake John it like what
are the chances that that devan's dad
doesn't scream and instead just like
grabs a hammer I guess that's a good
point I hadn't I hadn't thought of that
and thought of the snake murder issue
okay alternate alternate I guess it
depends it depends on your dad Devon
alternately what if you go to your dad
this is a strategy that I used a few
times
in in my own adolescence what if you go
to your dad with something really big
and then say just kidding I got a snake
you know right like what if you go to
your dad and you say you know how we've
been planning for that big trip that I'm
gonna make to college this whole time
I've been lying I didn't get into
college
yeah and I'm really sorry and dad's
gonna be like oh no this is a disaster
and then you can be like just kidding I
got a snake can I'm going to college and
the snakes coming with me and I'm going
to college notice that they know that
happened everything's fine everything
worked out better than expected it has
to be it has to be more than I didn't
get into college it's like instead of
I've decided instead of going to college
I'm going to go be truant like try my
hand at becoming a professional Pokemon
go player or yeah cuz I think I'm just
gonna stop you right there if I can and
just point out that playing Pokemon go
for a living is a completely legitimate
career and if you want to do with your
life I support you 100% not actually not
if you're my child I just want to be
clear if every if you're visiting this
podcast in the future and you think this
is it means that's okay for you to play
pokemon go if not you other people's
kids yeah all right well I think that I
think we've created a bunch of different
potential options for Devin and he's
gonna have to choose which brothers path
to go here but I'm not backing down and
I think that this light can be
maintained through through college
admissions do you remember the person
who wanted to learn how to play the
fiddle and and spring it upon their
whole family yeah uh-huh
that's a good lie I wish that they could
meet up with Devin and maybe like do the
background music when Devin's doing the
big reveal to Devin Brad or maybe that
person could just show up while they're
packing the car and then start playing
fiddle and Evan's Evan's dad's gonna be
like who is this person who's playing
the fiddle in my driveway at walls shake
into the car yeah perfect
all right Hank but why don't you ask a
question okay I have one this question
is from Olivia who asks dear Hank and
John I'm a senior in college and I've
always struggled the balance between
pushing myself to become better and
being comfortable with who I am I think
it's important to strive for
self-improvement but there are some
parts of me that I'd like to accept as
just Who I am
for example I'm an introvert but I want
to push myself to meet new people and do
things that make me uncomfortable
because I know that leads to rewarding
experiences on the other hand I also
hope that even if the world favours
extroverts I can still succeed while
being introverted and I shouldn't need
to conform to certain societal standards
thanks love the pod
it makes walk into class in the freed
and cold weather bearable best wishes
Olivia Olivia I think being comfortable
with who you are and being like
comfortable are different like
completely different things they're not
related to each other like you can be
like comfortable with who you are and
still do things that are uncomfortable
and you will be uncomfortable in those
situations but not because you're
uncomfortable with you know you as a
person I do lots of stuff that I dislike
and that makes me uncomfortable
but but I I feel like I'm pretty good at
actually knowing who I am and being
comfortable with who I am so if you
think that something's going to lead to
a rewarding experience but you don't
want to do it because you just don't
want to do it but you think but you but
you also like you recognize that there's
a benefit to doing it you have to decide
whether the discomfort is worth the
reward
which is sounds like it's exactly what
you're doing it sounds like you are
comfortable with who you are and you are
also trying to make decisions not just
based on whether you're gonna be happy
in the moment when you make those
decisions or when you do the thing but
also once you're gonna be like
considering the potential effects of the
decisions that you make beyond just how
you're gonna feel in that moment and I
would argue that that shows a lot of
self-awareness and I think you're doing
a good job yeah I agree I think it's
important to stretch yourself but also
to take care of yourself and that
balance is like for me like the great
challenge of adulthood yeah yeah
absolutely doing doing things that you
don't want to do that you have to do
making choices that you don't want to
make you know like getting the thing
done when you don't want to get it done
I think that that like that's the that's
one of the most valuable like things
that a person can get good at no I agree
let's answer another serious question
Hank while we're on the serious question
front all right okay Hank this question
comes from Sam who writes hello John and
Hank Mike dad has a new girlfriend and
she's amazing and sweet and a perfect
fit to our family so far the only thing
is she uses offensive words I'm actually
not even gonna say the words Hank that
are in this email because why why would
I they're very hurtful words though
about gay people and mentally disabled
people Sam goes on to write I know words
only have power if you give them power I
think that's not quite true but when she
says these things I can't help but feel
gross inside as someone who is gay and
has mentally disabled friends I know the
true power of those words I just don't
know if telling her to stop gives her
words more power or if just leaving it
alone makes them just words mangoes and
monkeys Sam huh that's a tough one yeah
I I would almost go to my dad first and
say this it's really hard for me it's
really hard for me to hear this person
who's becoming part of our families say
say these things not just because
they're hurtful and and kind of explain
why they're hurtful I know that can be
really difficult to do but I also think
that the vast majority of the time when
you explain to someone why the language
they're using is hurtful they stop yeah
yeah and I mean it can definitely feel
like it you know the the first impulse
is always going to be defensive for that
person who's being confronted and so
it's really it's important to recognize
that and to try and like make allowances
for that and and be like yeah I know I'd
like I know that it this is kind of
feels like an attack but like here's the
sitch
and I do think that John's right like
going to your dad is a good idea and
it's also nice that this is a person
that you like in that Lake
you know suit like seems like a pretty
cool person except that like maybe they
just aren't aware that this is like that
they're people out there who are gonna
be like really you know like maybe this
person just isn't aware that this like
that it's a thing and I think that like
frankly you know a lot of us didn't know
that and and like we are all constantly
learning and and and hopefully the the
the your dad's new girlfriend to be open
to that learning but I yeah I don't
think it's necessarily something that
you should just ignore and it but
hopefully you have a good enough
relationship with your dad that you
could be like hey what do you what do
you think about this yeah I think it's
really hard to ignore when someone is
using language that kind of dehumanizes
you or you know takes away some of your
personhood and and I don't think you
should be expected to ignore it but at
the same time I think Hanks right that
people do you know they are gonna feel
defensive and but that's part of that
you know hopefully that's part of the
learning process for them and then
something that you know it's unfortunate
that you know you're put in a situation
where you have to stand up for yourself
and for your friends but but yeah it
seems like that's that's the reality so
I wish you luck Hank can I ask another
question I'm very fond of this next one
all right your podcast it's not my
podcast you answered that question about
the water cycle it was fascinating is
question comes from Ryan who writes Dear
John and Hank from where I'm currently
sitting in my school's engineering
building I can hear a rather loud and
emotional phone call between someone and
their ex who are trying to be friends
from what I can tell it's not going well
I need some it I I have some advice that
I would like to shout down the hall but
I am not sure if that's considered okay
please respond soon as shouted advices
clearly needed someone lying about their
name right Brian the only reason I asked
the question was cuz I thought your name
was actually Ryan ah come on
I'm very frustrated I decided to sign
off before I chose to read the question
anyway Brian that is a terrible idea
yes yes
do not shout advice to strangers in a
school engineering building when they
are going through a difficult time
that is extremely presumptuous you must
always wait to be asked for advice
before you offer it you know the only
time I've ever shouted advice to people
to a stranger
the only time is while driving and they
can't hear me and it's like you
shouldn't do that or use your turn
signal like those are the shots that I
shout at strangers you know it occurred
to me just now that I actually shout
advice at strangers every week while I'm
watching soccer right yes that's in fact
I spend most of my time watching soccer
shouting advice to Liverpool Football
Club players who I don't know purse most
sports viewing is is shouting advice to
sports players I think that is the vast
majority of what what watching sports is
and in some times here on dear Hank and
John we shout advice to strangers like I
could I could shout right now no
absolutely but we are asked it's people
who are asking us for advice it's not
like yeah I overhear someone having an
unpleasant phone conversation that they
probably want to be having in private
but you know they have a right mate or
whatever so like the closest they can
come to privacy is this they're
miserable study Carole in the
engineering building and they're there
in the middle of the worst conversation
they've ever had in their whole life
like the thing you probably don't want
to hear is like you'll never
successfully be friends with your ex
just stop trying it's not gonna work
okay okay I seriously no it's probably
not gonna work
thankfully I think we've settled this
one pretty well I'm good this question
comes from Brian who asks dear it's not
even Ryan Brian D Ranga John in a Star
Trek it appears that most space ships
are owned by owned by governments
whereas in Star Wars the space ship
ownership seems to be more distributed
with government governments owning some
ships companies owning ships and even
individuals having their own private
spacecraft do you think an our future
will follow more the Star Trek model and
have large spaceships owned by
governments or perhaps large
corporations that probably like our mass
transit or will it be more like Star
Wars where individuals can buy their own
private spaceships if they
aren't john and actually one-to-one can
we we could assume of course that none
of this would happen until 2028 or later
life is life if the life is a thing to
do between periods of non-existence
Brian it's beautiful yeah this is an
interesting question Hank you know what
it reminded me of it reminded me of my
relationship with boats like maybe in
the future space crab maybe in the
future spacecrafts will be like boats
where you know you want to have friends
who own one but you don't want to own
one yourself
it's like it's like the worst the worst
purchase you've ever made is your boat
and you just like and it just sits there
in space dock right guys you know it's
more like I want to have a boat than I
actually want to use like you think
you're gonna travel the galaxy but
there's so many costs associated with
the actual use of the spacecraft over
and above the initial cost of the
spacecraft and that's kind of a bummer
and must like you think you're gonna be
free on weekends but it turns out that
like once your kids get to a certain age
they've got soccer practice every
weekend and like it's just it's really
hard to get away from your life long
enough to travel the galaxy I can
totally see that future yeah yep that's
certainly like if we don't change
dramatically as a culture which I don't
like and a species I don't really
imagine that we yell it does seem like
we're more headed for an either case
where it's just like rich people have
space boats but for the most part they
they don't use them and they just sit
there and they cost money
yeah like the space-boat market is like
rich people but the people who actually
like ride in the space boats are the
sailors or whatever who run that the
ship that the rich person owns and
rarely uses it'll be like one of those
situations where you'll be talking to
somebody and you'll say so where do you
spend the summer's and they'll say well
you know we've got a house on Mars but
it's just we can never get away for
longer than two weeks and it takes two
weeks just to get there
oh man
I don't I don't like our imagining of
the future job it's always that the Star
Trek model has always been really
interesting to me because it's like
these people get paid like this is their
job or is this because the idea of Star
Trek if you like look into the economics
is it's very like a post-capitalist
future where they're like people don't
it's it's almost like they get some kind
of universal basic income and the form
of like energy credits and then but if
you want to get it if you want to like
have a space boat you got to work for
the United Federation of Planets you
can't just like get a space boat yeah I
mean I feel really bad for the people of
the future although I can I can I just
pause real quick to make a note of
something sure it used to be that
pessimism was my thing like that was my
that was my brand that was my thing
oblivion was coming for us and
everything was darkness and bla bla bla
bla bla that was mine and now I feel
like everyone has taken it away from me
and they've made it their thing and
suddenly it's very cool and him to be
extremely pessimistic and to think that
the world is going to hell in a
handbasket and to think that you know
everything's turning to crap I am a
little annoyed by having had my thing
taken away from me I uh I was
pessimistic way before it was cool you
know like I I liked pessimism 'he's
early albums and it's annoying to me
that now like pessimism is selling out
these big stadium shows and it's not and
it almost makes me want to be optimistic
it almost makes me think that maybe
pessimism was wrong all along well John
I encourage you to to switch sides but
yeah it does kind of feel like that
happened and I don't know it seems like
since like November or something like I
don't know it makes like something
something drap dramatic changed and it's
like something very weird happened in
November in America and suddenly my
pessimism is on it's like it's
everywhere and I even feel like my
pessimism is overexposed at this point
you know what spaceships are gonna look
like they're gonna be awesome and
they're gonna be available to everyone
they're gonna cost like five bucks and
they're gonna travel faster than light
and it's gonna be great
everything is going to be amazing
the future is gonna rule today's podcast
is brought to you by the awesome awesome
future ruling it totally got a rule that
awesome future this podcast is also
brought to you by Secret snakes
snick secret snakes wrapped around
Devon's middle with an ace bandage so
his dad doesn't know that these been
lying for six months out of a secret
snake for six months yeah what is it
once it's been that long just keep it a
secret no I totally disagree with you
I'm saying like but how on earth do you
what like how do you make it for six
months like how do you get in the frozen
grass at some point does your dad like
look in a bag and say like hey is that a
frozen Mouse what's uh what's that all
about why are there a bunch of frozen
mice in the freezer what's going on Oh
today's podcast is also but brought to
you by blue apron blue apron just one of
the very best meal delivery services
available I'm sorry I think I'm trying
to get an actual sponsor okay I'm trying
to like model what it would look like if
we had proper sponsorship on this
podcast what uh
Caitlin Hofmeister the producer of
scishow suggested that we have our fake
sponsors be brought to you by a real
sponsor oh that's so it would be like
the today's podcast is brought to you by
Secret snakes which is brought to you by
audible.com thanks they're wrapped
around every that wrapped around Devon's
middle and they're brought to you by
audible the world's largest resource for
your audio entertainment just what's
real I just want some real sponsors uh
you have to do the last fake sponsor
okay our final speaks fake sponsor of
the evening is peeing wherever but not
at a toilet though cuz that's it's not
good for the hydrological cycle or
something yeah also you don't want to
pee too near like like like you know a
river or a lake because you don't want
to you know we're station anyway Hank I
want to ask a question this comes from
Dallas but I think I might have asked
too many of the recent questions so I
think I'm gonna ask you to read it so it
seems like you're picking okay John one
last question before we get to the
all-important
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon this is
from Dallas who asks dear Hank and John
Facebook has a feature that allows you
to see what you posted on that day in
the years past and I'm always so
interested in what I was doing at this
time in the past when I look at 2016 in
2015 nothing has changed in the way I
post that much only in that I post on
Facebook maybe once a week rather than
once a day when I go back further than
just a couple of years we meet high
school Dallas she was a terribly
embarrassing human she thought that it
was hilarious to post only the punchline
to an inside joke with absolutely no
context she also saw fit to narrate her
daily life with posts like just got from
hope just got home from school super
hungry HMU I don't know what HMU is I
was hmm you stand for I don't know
hey stop everything and figure out what
HMU stands for before we answer the rest
heat my uranium HMU does it does it
stand for hold something like hold my
unicorn it's hit me up hit me up like
via text okay yeah hit me up okay
I'm completely ashamed to admit that
Dallas is and I'm completely ashamed to
admit that that Dallas is in fact me why
did I do this in my youth is that
something everyone did in high school or
middle school or is it just something
that people did in 2010 to 2014
perplexed and perturbed Dallas Hank I
don't know how you feel about this but I
feel like that has that pattern has
continued in my life well yeah were you
looking back at like who you were five
years ago and you're like yeah pretty
cringy there's some there's some cringe
there's not it's not like it's not like
this particular thing Dallas you're
gonna have to learn this it's not that
you like we're doing a particular thing
just got home from school super hungry
hm you know that person is cringy not
because of that particular behavior but
because you know go hang out with a
person who is four years younger than
yourself and you'll be like yeah there's
a reason why I don't do that
yeah I mean I feel like my past cells
were all huge embarrassments to me but I
also feel that my present self will
never be embarrassing to future me
because present me is so cool calm and
collected but I've always felt that but
like yeah I look back at my high school
South and I am so grateful that the
things that I wrote and thought in high
school were not archived on Facebook to
reappear once a year when I wrote them
and and even like when I look back at
Looking for Alaska or even Paper Towns I
feel a little even The Fault in Our
Stars at this point like when I look
back at my old work I always just feel
like oh god oh no yikes did you really
did you really have to like when I look
back at Looking for Alaska I and I only
you know have glanced at the actual text
of the book in the last 10 years but
like did you have to use the verb
deadpan 12 to 15 times did you did you
have to I was it that great of a verb
yeah there really should be like a piece
of software you can run your book
through to make sure that you don't use
a word way way way more than it is used
on average and if you do then you are
you are making that oh oh yeah to be
clear though my publisher Julie Strauss
gable was like you need to stop using
the word dead penned in this book like
it appears like 14 times and that's
probably 13 times too many and I was
like you don't understand
deadpan is a verb of right now it is the
way to describe how people of right now
talk and you don't get it because you
don't have your finger on the pulse of
America's youth the way I do and now I'm
just like oh god
well congratulations congratulations on
ruining Looking for Alaska for
absolutely everyone with that analysis
now and I can't I will never be able to
read the book again without searching
for deadpans I will say that I think
that we're much more critical of our
past selves than we are of actual people
who are that age in my experience when I
like look it when I
get like me from high school I'm like ah
whereas when I look at an actual current
high school student I'm like you're
pretty cool so that's interesting
they're just trying to figure stuff out
that's the thing like you know when when
you said now that I understand what HMU
means like what what high school Dallas
was trying to do was you know like
connect to people which is a good thing
to do and when high school Dallas is
posting the punch line to an inside joke
with no context like high school Dallas
is really trying to connect to the few
other people who will get that joke and
feel like they're on the inside of
something because like when when you're
a teenager you really want to feel like
you're part of a community that cares
about you and like you have a special
relationship with your friends yeah I
don't judge that Dallas at all by the
way but high school me was a total total
cringe back yeah I mean it's also it's
interesting that like we we think of
ourselves as this like as like they're
the me that I have right now continues
back into the past in a way that it
doesn't actually do like I am different
from my from what I was back then and I
think that's part of the cringe it's
like being like oh that's not who I
imagined myself to be but I that is me
and I have to come to terms of that and
that's fine and like maybe you should
spend a little time trying to try to be
a little more forgiving to pass to
Dallas because you're gonna change in
the future and you should be okay with
those changes in whatever directions
they're they're taking you I'm still not
there I have to say that sounds like a
lovely sentiment but it seems impossible
to actually make happen in my life Hank
what is the news from Mars in AFC
Wimbledon so at the end of every podcast
for those of you who are new we give you
the news from Mars which is a planet an
AFC Wimbledon which is a third tier
English soccer team do you want me to go
first because I'm ready yeah go ahead
Hank just yesterday as we're recording
this notice you're listening to haha AFC
Wimbledon played Rockdale or possibly
roachdale or possibly Rochdale rosianna
honey say Rockdale Rochdale apparently
but Britisher and hank as you will
recall AFC wimbledon were only a couple
of points away from certain safety in
league 1
meaning that we get another season of
Ligue 1 football ahead of us and what
should happen in that game in the 44th
minute there was a red card from a
Rochdale roachdale but I still can't
remember even from five seconds ago a
player and that red card led to that
player being sent off whereupon AFC
Wimbledon in quick succession scored
three goals one of which Hank was a
penalty and the the penalty taker who
ended up being Dean parrot was decided
when while Taylor and Dean parrot did a
game of rock-paper-scissors to decide
which of them was going to take the
penalty Dean parrot won that game of
rock-paper-scissors scored the goal AFC
Wimbledon win 3-1 now after 40 games
with just six games remaining in their
Ligue 1 season AFC Wimbledon are on 54
points and basically well I will say it
at this point they are assured of safety
one more season in the third tier of
English football for Wimbledon huzzah
congratulations that's good exciting
that's very exciting I'm sorry that he's
probably not moving up but maybe if you
just win everything and but but
hopefully what it what it means is that
AFC Wimbledon will continue to have more
money to spend on on its players on its
fans on its it's pitch and that's that's
good for everybody
you know what else you know what else is
good for everybody John what water you
you know how there's water on Mars right
like there's currently lots of frozen
water on Mars but also that we have lots
of evidence that at one point there was
lots of liquid water standing on the
surface of Mars there were big lakes
there was even potentially a giant ocean
in some of the lower lying northern
parts of Mars and we have evidence and
we have had evidence for some time of a
massive tsunami so the cool thing about
Mars is that like because there is no
water now a lot of old things stick
around for much longer the
they went on earth because old stuff on
earth gets washed away by the water
because we have active plate tectonics
that refreeze shapes the surface of the
earth and then we also have just water
falling on earth dissolving stuff making
mountains run into the ocean and etc so
but you can see evidence of stuff
hanging around on Mars from much longer
ago because there is currently no
hydrological cycle and also plate
tectonics don't seem to be a thing so we
have this evidence of this tsunami that
occurred about three billion years ago
and it is a massive tsunami talking like
a hundred meter tall wave now the waves
can be taller over because there's less
gravity but it was also a high-speed
thing so traveling at about sixty meters
per second so a very fast very big wave
of water that that we have evidence of
sort of slamming into various parts we
could see it all sort of all over areas
of Mars so we knew that there is a there
was a big ocean there because there has
to be has to be a big ocean first
tsunami happened and we also now as of
like this week think that we have found
the crater that is risk that that was
caused by the meteorite responsible for
creating the tsunami which is pretty
cool so we can see like sort of the
tsunami radiating out of one place in
the in the the this large northern ocean
which is sort of like the northern area
northern hemisphere of Mars is sort of
more depressed not entirely sure why but
we think that there was a long-standing
long lasting ocean that was there and a
few billion years ago and that we can
see you know sort of like the deposits
left behind by this tsunami and also
potentially probably the like the actual
crater that caused this event it's
pretty frickin cool that is pretty
amazing so some kind of large object
hits Mars four billion years ago and
there is a huge tsunami and we are able
to know the approximate timeline in
which all of this happened because
science yeah and and injure like even
like cool
literally is a big enough meteor that
like it blew the water out and then
there was sort of a reverse tsunami as
it came back into the hole that was left
oh wow so there's like we can see
evidence of both of these tsunamis the
one that went out and then the one like
this like sort of rebound tsunami that
was smaller but still really substantial
that is cool that is really cool so
that's Mars for you yeah I mean that's
that might be the coolest Mars news that
we've had in this whole podcast that was
fascinating Thank You Hank and we are
now going to go record this week in
Ryan's our weekly plasmas that you can
get access to at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John every week we record a
brief podcast as a supplement to this
one in which we talk about Orion do you
know what Ryan were talking about this
week Hank I don't I thought that was
your job Ryan Adams is it right Adams
that's exciting I actually an atom's I
know a couple of Ryan Adams facts
already so I'm I'm rearing to go well I
appreciate you preparing in advance well
I you could get that over at patriot
that come slash dear Hank and John Hank
what did we learn today we learned that
both Hank and John have embarrassing
signature stories though Hanks it's more
embarrassing and of course we learned
that the water that you use to water
your lawn is drinking water
we learned that HMU stands for hold my
unicorn and lastly we learned that when
you hear a couple having a fight over
the phone do not bill advice across the
hallway now you can only have advice to
strangers in two situations while
driving in traffic and while watching
sports that's right alright Hank thank
you for potting with me thanks to
everybody for listening you can email us
at Hank and John at gmail.com you can
also use the hashtag dear Hank and John
on Twitter where Hank is Hank green and
I am with some in frequency John Green
dear Hank and John is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
our editor is Nicholas Jenkins Victoria
van Giorno as our head of community
in communications and our music is by
the great gunnarolla and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]